former New Orleans Mayor Mitch Landrieu
helped lead the charge to remove
Confederate statues in his city now he's
leading an initiative that calls for a
reckoning with the legacy of racism the
nonprofit a pluribus unum works to
achieve social and racial justice in the
u.s. the efforts name is taken of course
from the u.s. motto that means out of
many one its first report divided by
design interesting title offers a
comprehensive look at race and class
issues in the South Landrieu and his
team talked to more than 800 people from
28 communities in 13 different states he
joins us at the table to unpack what he
found out how did you decide where you
were going and who you were going to
talk to specific I'm gonna answer that
question but I'm stunned I went to Peter
lubbers when we traveled across the
south it was terrific we went to 28
different counties we went to 13
different states so we criss cross we
were people that you talk to like talk
to everybody we took well everybody that
that that is african-american white you
know educated non-college educated I
mean we we wanted to get on the ground
and talk to and listen to people we
conducted over 800 interviews some of
them lasted longer than a half an hour
45 minutes where we talked to individual
people so that we can listen in here and
get out of this noise that you hear all
the time from Washington DC and get back
on the ground so we came up with /
design what does that mean yeah well it
what it means as it is that there is a
big difference the way people see the
world everybody wants equal opportunity
for themselves they want the kids to
have a better life but the
african-american community views the
obstacles there differently from the
white community yeah white folks that
responded to the survey think that
racism is just an individual act of
malice to another person that looks
different from them african-americans
say that's not our experience while they
accept that as a form of racism because
they feel it every day
they say the institutions that we have
are still baked with institutional
designs and so the point is the country
is the way it is because we designed it
this way right and so if we want a
different outcome we have to redesign it
so criminal justice reform for example
would run into this education reform how
you gerrymander legislative districts
that are etc but Mitch how do you
advance this conversation because to get
to those
you talk about you have to you have to
get support from the white community to
do it yeah there's no question and the
first thing that has to happen is people
need to get to know each other spend
time with each other see each other's
humanity and you have to do this on the
ground you have to do with family in the
family neighborhood the neighborhood
church the church team - team and
community to community you heard many
white people say listen this happened
how can you hold us accountable for
something that happened - 150 years and
when it comes to reparations what would
you the way that we talk about this is
listen it may not be your fault yeah but
it is certainly your responsibility so
in the last segment you had climate
change you know what the impact is going
to be in a couple years demographic
changes if we don't get together across
race in class the chances of us dealing
with those complicated issues that are
going to stress us it's going to make
the country worse and finally the reason
we use a pluribus unum is because of
founding fathers from our origin set out
of many we are one now the good thing
about the poll is that everybody thinks
that diversity is a strength not a
weakness and of course that issue is
being challenged on the national level
yeah on the ground in America most
people in the south that responded to
this survey liked the fact that they
live around it but we're kind of
segregated in isolation right now and we
have to work our way out of that if we
want to be strong and be the country
that we all say we aspire to be many of
these issues come up in the democratic
primary race for president here and I
know you said you're not gonna run in
2020 but I'm curious if someone asked
you to be vice president would you be
interested
[Laughter]
you've been you opted not as we
mentioned you you're not running you've
been very supportive of former Vice
President Joe Biden are you still a fan
well I haven't endorsed anybody yet but
people have asked me and I think he is
our best chance to do what I think the
country really wants to do which is turn
a corner and have a new president so
that we can reclaim what America really
is supposed to be I think you listen I
think people that are worried about it
or more worried I think he's doing fine
think about it he's been out there he's
gotten everything but the kitchen sink
thrown at him from everybody he still
stand if he's still leading and he still
is going well it's a long campaign there
are lots of candidates from my
perspective any one of them would be
exponentially better than what we have
right now and given what you're seeing
in Washington today the country wants to
make a change and I think they will what
do you think about the lieutenant
colonel who
defied yesterday highly credentialed and
now he's being attacked to someone I
think that not patriotic here's the
thing at some point in time the Senators
need to put that country above the party
and the information that's coming out
from people who are Republicans that
were appointed by the president that
served this country honorably and
actually will wound it who themselves a
very credible people should be given
great weight impeachment is a very
sobering thing it should be handled that
way and the Congress should do their
duty the American people are smart
enough to figure this out over time the
other impeachment process that Nixon
went through took a long long period of
time so I think walking through this
very soberly but to attack somebody's
credibility like here the ambassador
testified they're very credible
witnesses and their stories ring true
from anybody that's ever served on a
jury and I've served two it sounds
pretty credible that they were able to
see and hear and know what occurred and
then the stories make sense so let the
evidence fall where it made but don't
don't don't malign this man's character
who bled fraud card there was one thing
from your report that I thought was
interesting you said talent is equally
distributed but opportunity isn't that
did not come from you that came from
high school students in Louisville
Kentucky looked at me and said mr. Mehra
well you know we're out here we're
working hard we're all good we're smart
but we can't get ahead you know talent
out here is equally distributed but our
opportunities are not and if the country
could just stay focused on that so that
everybody has equal opportunity and
everybody has a fair shot we've got a
chance as a country to get where we say
we want to thank you for nudging our
focus and that yeah sure Landrieu great
decision